about 65 million years ago a mass
extinction event occurred wiping out
more than 75% of all species on earth
there have only been five mass
extinctions in our planets
four-and-a-half billion year history but
the next one has already started by the
end of this century one in six species
on earth could be gone will humans go
with them
how could we survive a sixth mass
extinction how could we prevent one this
is what F and here's what would happen
if we set aside half our planet for
wildlife the reason we're all still
alive on this planet is thanks to
biodiversity from the tallest trees to
the biggest animals to the weirdest
plants to the grossest fungi to the
buzziest bugs and even the creatures you
can't see we all rely on each other to
make life on Earth possible and our
world would be harmonious except that
the humans are unreliable thanks to our
unstable practices the world's wildlife
is inching towards an extinction rate
that's 10,000 times faster than what's
considered to be natural without taking
drastic action we might be facing
extinction ourselves
but how far are we willing to go
Pulitzer prize-winning author and
biologist Leo Wilson came up with what
is now known as the half earth idea it
involves making half the planet a human
free zone leaving nature to do what it
can to stabilize itself this means that
the current global population of roughly
seven point seven billion people would
have to make do with half the space we
currently have and for a lot of people
that's just not feasible cordoning off
half the world for extreme conservation
would displace roughly 1 billion people
most of them from low-income backgrounds
think of those parts of the world where
overpopulation is severe and then
imagine that situation everywhere but
housing isn't our only concern we also
need food and fresh water to survive
today one-third of the Earth's land
surface and 75% of its freshwater
resources are used for crop and
livestock production yet at least 10% of
Earth's population doesn't have enough
food how many more people will go hungry
when we no longer have access to those
resources economically speaking the
forest and fuel industries could
collapse because there'd be less land to
work with this would leave millions of
people out of work but the losses might
be recouped in the form of new
opportunities in more sustainable fields
in fact setting aside half the planet
for environmental protection wouldn't be
a total financial disaster five hundred
and seventy seven billion dollars in
annual global crops are currently at
risk due to pollinator loss while
roughly forty percent of the world's
economy as a whole
relies on biological resources if we
continue down the path were on we risk
depleting the bee population in its
entirety as well as other biological
resources we depend on but by protecting
them their declining numbers
may have the opportunity to regenerate
so that we can continue to benefit from
their output in a sustainable way of
course it's not just about the money the
fact is that the more biodiverse and
ecosystem is the healthier it is a
healthy ecosystem can clean water help
to purify the air we breathe regulate
the climate maintain the soil needed for
crops and food plus recycle nutrients
while we're at it
in short we can't afford to continue
living in a way that accelerates the
extinction of other species because we
need them as much as they need us the
half earth idea might be too much
in fact it's virtually impossible to
implement but the consequences of doing
the bare minimum would be even worse
we've got to spread the word and remind
each other that we're all in this
together
no matter how big no matter how small
because every time a species goes
extinct it brings humans closer to our
own extinction don't believe me have you
ever wondered what would happen to us if
all the world's insects disappeared
well that's a story for another what if
[Music]